so I have to eat trying to hide his
attack right with his displacement and
it's got it from us he does an overt
pushy like my dad all right oh you
concede that one of the pleasures right
it's not going to work he does the
Atocha hard to my hands go the hearts
out it's not going to work I'm going to
see it coming so vivid the first move is
very settled that he's not feeling so
the first displacement is with the
movement you see his swords already
offline and I just need a tiny bit oh
and i occupy this better it's hard to
feel right is that the sword looks like
right he success that so now he's doing
it backwards are you going and I'm going
to feel his Center ever so slight and
now I'm going to make my defense in
receivables and against the bullpen
looks like you go on
so then he will finish his intention and
I will have my cut he will run into my
weapon
[Music]
we're training the same thing right
he tried to press on the center of I was
running for insulin center she realizes
it i release my tension first drill I
would feel like pushing up my dinner and
I'm free head and then finding the whole
you got it back to me then the next
drill I want to be as close as I can
roll to that one because there is a
perfect place in time to be and that's
what I'm looking for that's all I'm
doing the whole time Rome Rome full the
wrist cutter
[Music]